hi there steve coffman here and i am
here to announce
the next 90 day challenge
starting on september 1. now i'm not
going to tell you which language i'm
going to study
originally i was going to do korean but
i did korean the last time and i did i
improved but i didn't get as far as i
wanted to and i want to take my korean
to the next level but i'm not going to
do it this time i'm going to maybe
continue a little bit of korean you know
the 80 20 rule but 80 of my time is
going to be on a new language and i will
announce that in a later video
why do we have the 90-day challenge
because
you know we're learning
many of us are on link or many of us are
learning
independently
and we all know that if you go to a gym
you're likely to work yourself harder
than if you just stay at home and do
some exercises
so here again we're trying to create
some of that group pressure
a little bit of focus
some short-term goals
so that we can take ourselves up to
another level so if you're a beginner
you can get to where you're at least a
little familiar with the language if
you're at a low intermediate level you
want to take yourself to sort of a
breakthrough stage so that you can enjoy
more movies more books
enjoy talking to people more you may
have your own specific goals it doesn't
matter what they are
but if you join us in this 90 day
challenge
then
you'll be part of this group trying to
take ourselves to a new level in our
language
um i will be
i won't be putting up videos every day
as i did the last time but maybe twice a
week and blogging and talking about what
i'm doing
uh three other
members of our link team my son mark
plus sam and kieran are also going to be
participating in the 90-day challenge
and they'll be talking about their own
experiences and so we'll all be
commenting about what we're doing
we want you people to ask us questions
if you have any uh i should point out
that in addition to my um
once a week sort of reflections on my
activity type
video
i'm also going to have one video a week
where i will answer questions from other
participants and so all of this will be
laid out later on so this is kind of
like uh
uh advanced
news release that this is going to start
happening
on the 1st of september and you'll be
hearing more about it
in another video so stay tuned and i
hope as many of you as possible
join us
thanks for listening
bye for now